5 25 and you're finally Friday here's a
follow-up to the story of the Bonanza
High School Junior ROTC drill team that
won the Clark County School District
Championship back in April
at the multi-service national drill team
championships in Daytona Florida earlier
this month they picked up right where
they left off numerous inspections
judges watching their every move fans
cheering
[Music]
parents showing their support
chilling behind the scenes
first sergeant Greg Sanders reports the
Bengal Battalion took home a bunch of
trophies and second place in the country
in the unarmed team category
the young men and women did take time
for a day of fun at the beach but just
as the Sands of Time March on their
teacher sergeant major David oberg
announced to the students that after 18
years of Bonanza he too is moving on but
not before letting the kids know how
proud he is
oberg told me they practice an hour
before school every day after school
three days a week two Saturdays a month
he says the cadets showed the discipline
character determination and teamwork
that's required to succeed in
competition and in life we always want
to know what's cool it's cool if you got
something let us know cool let's cool
under the Community tab of our website
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com